tell her i said hello i like her yeah
she's great i love you
oh my god here she comes she's a huge
fan of yours
and i'm a huge fan of yours i think
you're so funny
oh my god first i love nailed it but
also every time you come on the show and
you make conan just so
uncomfortable such a like repressed
irish catholic my favorite thing i love
you you're probably one of my favorite
guests that's ever been on the show
oh my thank you
so you love that nicole makes me
uncomfortable because i'm so repressed
yes all right good nicole you are a
single
lady now now yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
if it's attached to a nice person okay
what a bonus
if you're looking for a nice guy is what
you said sure
not in that order no nice can come
last yeah just oh a nice deep oh yes
my wife's always assured me that doesn't
matter
[Applause]
[Laughter]
maybe her order's different yeah yeah
you know nice first
yeah yeah big things no no or medium
things let's not assume that i'm saying
anything
you told me once that you keep notes
on all the people you've dated yes you
rate them and you keep notes on them
what's in these notes
just go through the date did i have fun
was he creative was he boring do you
have a big
was it curves was it straight wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute
it sounds like you have you mentioned it
and then when you get to penis
there's all these subcategories yes
well no penises alike so you gotta rate
them
you know so so i have a a memory of it
so i can return back to the google doc
and be like
ah tim tim was curved to the left but
tim
hit it good do they know that you're
writing all this down
at the moment insane no imagine i'm just
like riding him i'm like wait a second
okay okay come on
[Applause]
one of the girls gave me a giant dildo
as a gift as a joke yeah
as a gift i like them i have like
i i i said as a joke and you but you
appreciated the gift
no i love penises i have a penis earring
in my
ear because i just love them so much
but anyway she oh that was an imagining
thing
i love them i thought i was seeing that
when it wasn't there
no it's not and i was questioning things
no i see penises
everywhere so so she gave me this giant
dildo as a present
and i couldn't fit it into my luggage
that's it's that big it was like two
feet tall
it was huge and i was like
i'm just going to leave it in the rental
car so
i get to budget rental car and i put it
in the back seat and as i was getting
out the guy
looked in looked at me looked at it and
then we had an
understanding that i was leaving a
present
and then i walked away and i heard them
laugh so hard
yeah and it brought me joy and then i
was like maybe this is my new thing i
become like the dildo fairy
i'm on five dating apps i'm on tinder
bumble raya hinge okay cupid that's six
i'm sad uh it's so
hard i just it's just someone said ah
thank you thank you that's someone are
you very
open about what it is you're looking for
when you're on social media yes my
profile picture has me holding like a
like a foot long dildo
so i'm just like
you know be up front with what you want
women we just we don't tell people what
we want we're just quiet we need to be
like give it to me
okay i'm right with you
i don't know i don't know what happened
i think it's a remarkable quality you
have i grew up not liking anything about
myself
but why conan you're tall that's
luxurious
you have red hair how exotic you have
all your teeth what a treat
i noticed you i noticed a tattoo when
you came in do you have a lot you have a
bicycle there do you have a lot of
tattoos i have
uh i think it's 15 now you have 15
tattoos i find them pretty well oh yeah
so
yeah i got a bicycle i have a pig i have
an elephant
i have a flamingo i'm a butt i have a
lollipop
ice cream cone and a cupcake that says
it's sweet just taste it
because i thought it was so funny maybe
a little asterisk and then just sort of
on your thigh it should say unless
you're diabetic
i'm just saying it should be a medical
disclaimer all right so that's
that's one butt cheek the next one
so what's on the other butt cheek a
chili pepper that says muy caliente
my mother used to say it takes more to
frown than it does to smile so i can be
like
[ __ ] you with a smile on my face you
know
i probably shouldn't have every question
i asked you go down a certain
way i'm not saying you're wrong
but i could ask you you know what's your
favorite thing about a rainbow
you know and you'll be like oh the
[Applause]
just like in the pot of gold
men have been so forward and honest for
such a long time yes
bosses would tell their secretaries like
wear a shorter skirt how come i can't
walk around be like wear sweatpants all
the time so i can see your dick print
print is what it's called when men wear
sweatpants they
show you what they're carrying around
and it's a real treat at the airport
people recognize me as a tsa agent
um wait do they really think you're a
tsa agent if you're a black woman in the
airport you're a tsa
agent truly
i had one woman she went through the
metal detector and she came back and she
looked at me and she was like i forgot
to take off my flip-flops
and then she handed them to me
and then i took them and i put them in
the bin i was like
she thinks i'm a tsa agent then i walked
through she was like they make you do
that too and i said yes they do
it would have been funny if you just
hung out there you probably could have
patted people down
then i'd go to jail and there'd be like
a terrible article written on vulture
about me
i was on a flight from louisiana to
atlanta then heading back to la
and i was on the descent and i was very
chilly so i said better cover up
and i pulled out the blanket out of the
sealed plastic bag
open it a little brown crumble falls on
me i was like oh me oh my what hath that
babe
but i forage ahead because i'm chilly so
i like open it more and i see this like
brown
thing in it so i drop it because i was
like is it an animal what is it
so then i open it with my foot this man
staring at me i'm in first class thank
you and
[Music]
the smell hits me and i was like oh my
god
oh my god i think that's a piece of poop
and then we
landed and i went up to the flight
attendant i was like do you hand
sanitizer i think there's a piece of
poop in my blanket he was like girl no
and i said yes girl yes go look so he
goes he looks and he goes oh my god i
gotta get my phone
[Applause]
he gets his phone he's snapping pictures
passengers are like
oh my word wow and i was like i know
and then i had to like make my
connecting flight so i tweeted at delta
they were like we'll give you 250 delta
dollars
i was like you give people more to get
off a oversold flight
there was poop in my blanket give me an
airplane so both my parents they're dead
and neither one of them left a will so i
was like i'm gonna be responsible i'm
going to leave a will
but also my will has a ton of stuff for
people to do
because after i die i really want you to
have to keep doing stuff for me
you're giving people assignments yes and
the lady who notarized my will told me i
could not do that but i was like they
don't know
what kind of stuff is in there i can't
say specific stuff because it's a secret
i keep
hinting to my friends what they have to
do but i won't fully tell them
but like i do want to be in a flame
casket with purple and glitter
i want to be in something [ __ ] so i
die as i lived
um also i want like a bunch of guys i
have slept with to like
rate me she was great she rode me well
all right no no no
no no no no no andy andy no
that's not right do you hate him it's
her funeral yeah right
i didn't realize that's where the saying
came from you're having a good time
yeah and then when i die i'll have even
more fun yeah where are you going
after i die yeah hopefully to a place
with lots of
all right
[Applause]
conan i adore you i'm happy what's that
mean conan
you and i have a chemistry
it just means uh it's undeniable you get
around me
and i get around you and you know what
i'm saying yeah
i can't wait to see you again conan